it is election day 2022 and as is often
the case on election days in the United
States everyone has their take everyone
has their view Everyone likes to say
this is the one thing that this is
really all about it's really you know in
times past it's really a referendum on
Trump or this is really about a
corporations versus individuals or
whatever and almost always there really
is no one thing and so I've resisted
that type of language but this time
there really kind of is the one big
thing the one big thing at stake here
today is are we going to make a move in
the direction of being for democracy
where the candidate that gets the most
votes wins and assumes office without
controversy or are we going to make
another move away from democracy where
even if you don't get the most votes
people claim you should still assume the
office you ran for and and they may even
be able to make it a reality
if we aren't careful and if we don't
make the correct votes today that is
fundamentally what today's election is
about imagine 20 50 100 years from now
and think about today as an inflection
point one story that could be told is
well Trump came to power in 2016. he was
defeated in 2020 after a very dangerous
four years of insanity and then the Maga
movement moved in in 2022 took over the
Senate and or house a bunch of the
governor's houses then as a result of
that was able to steal an election in
2024 leading to the end of American
democracy as we knew it in 2028 and on
downhill from there right that's one
story
that if we think about today as an
inflection point could be told 20 50 100
years from now
there's a different story which could be
told again because it's an inflection
point it could be Trump did come to
power in 2016 and then was defeated in
2020 after that very same dangerous four
years of insanity but then in 2022 a
little bit of Sanity returned there's
still tens of millions of lunatics and
we see them all the time but a little
bit just enough sanity returned
that the tens of millions of
anti-democracy lunatics were defeated on
November 8 2022 absolute disaster was
just barely averted and then things got
on to a more logical path in 26 and in
24 26 28 Etc
it's a Divergence point it's an
inflection point and those are two
possible stories that could be told
consider these contrasts uh Rolling
Stones uh azawin sub sang and Patrick
rice are reporting that quote Trump is
calling Republicans to ask how many
times they will impeach Biden if they
win tonight think of that now on the
other hand Joe Biden and Barack Obama
have been touring the country saying we
need to save democracy this is not
fundamentally about should the top tax
rate on the richest Americans be 35 37
or 39 percent
that's a question it's a perfectly
reasonable question and at times past we
talked a lot about questions like that
we're dealing with something very
different here okay now by the way in
the meantime Joe Biden is predicting
that Democrats win
on the basis of an improving economy
that's also possible we just don't know
based on the polling right now the
posters really don't know and we're
going to talk about that next but before
we do that I really hope every single
one of you that votes in the United
States has already voted or is planning
to vote and I keep getting this in my
email David I care about what's
happening but one vote never makes a
difference these elections never come
down to one vote so it's really hard to
feel like my vote actually matters and
I've been talking about this on our
streams lately I understand that feeling
I think the same thing when when has a
gubernatorial race or a senate race come
down to a single vote therefore my vote
doesn't matter wrong the way you have to
think about it is as follows
tons of people have that thought tons of
people consider staying home because it
never comes down to one vote and they
all say my vote isn't going to make the
difference here think about that as a
group you're a part of
and once you think about it that way
elections often come down to do the
people who wonder is my vote going to
make a difference does that constituency
does that group stay home or vote we all
have that thought
if every one of us who thought it never
comes down to a one vote I'll stay home
if we all do stay home we lose a bunch
of Elections that we could win okay so
don't fall for my vote doesn't make a
difference that's another way that these
right Wingers like to suppress the vote
don't let them do it we'll have results
live tonight on YouTube twitch and
Facebook starting at 7 30 Eastern
4 30 on the west coast if you have a
friend or loved one who is passionate
about the environment here is a perfect
holiday gift our sponsor established
titles is a project that lets you
ceremonially purchase as little as one
square foot of dedicated land in
edelston Scotland so that you can call
yourself a lord or a lady like the
historic Scottish tradition some people
even change their plane tickets or
credit cards to include Lord or lady
your title pack comes with an official
certificate you can see exactly where
your plot of land is located it makes a
perfect last minute gift but most
importantly established titles plants
one free tree for every plot of land
sold established titles does really good
work all over the world with
reforestation organizations like one
tree planted and trees for the future so
you'll have a great laugh whether you're
Scottish or not I'm not but you're
giving the gift of reforestation to
fight climate change if you use my link
you'll get 10 off and your plot of land
will be right next to mine you can see
it on a map go to establishtitles.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman for an
extra 10 off on top of their Black
Friday deal the link is down below